[Applaus]
der staat kapituliert vor dem wütenden
mob querdenken demo am samstag in
leipzig bis zu 40.000 menschen auf den
straßen corona leutner impfgegner und
neonazis seit an seit
die polizei zieht sie schließlich zurück
und lässt sie gewähren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die demonstranten marschieren auf dem
leipziger ring und kapern das motto der
friedlichen revolution von 1989
eine spirale der radikalisierung mit
ansage und weißt du was wir machen ist
dass wir unsere recht frei zu atmen
kämpfen deutschen botschaften frei zum
leben und frei unsere meinung kundtun
und dieses recht gut sich das deutsche
volk
die polizei steht mit viel zu wenigen
beamten viel zu vielen demonstranten
gegenüber und entscheidet sich
schließlich für rückzug
das polizeikonzept gescheitert es folgt
der politische streit unverantwortlich
war dass man mit dieser angekündigten
randale
so lässt sich umgegangen ist dass man
sich nicht entsprechend vorbereitet hat
dass die polizeikräfte vor ort auch
nicht in ausreichender zahl da waren
aber vor allem auch nicht dass man sich
darauf vorbereitet hat das ganz klar war
die auflagen werden nicht eingehalten
werden welche mittel hat man zur
verfügung um die einen um die
durchzusetzen
die haben am ende ja tatsächlich auch
noch mit einem verbotenen aufzug durch
die stadt die wirklich den start an der
nase durch den durch die manege gezogen
ich halte diese aussage für
granatenmäßig daneben frau essen muss
sich jetzt mal er selber fragen sie
kritisiert bei jeder gelegenheit die
polizei in deutschland und müsste sich
jetzt selber fragen ob wir nicht um
solche situationen wie auch in leipzig
zu verhindern nicht unsere polizei auch
mit bestimmten und mit mehr kompetenzen
ausstatten müssen eine demonstration
gegen die korona maßnahmen es war
absehbar dass die teilnehmer gegen
auflagen verstoßen würden also keine
maske und kein abstand und das
rechtsextreme aufmarschieren
auch keine überraschung wurde ganz
extrem auf extrem rechten netzwerken
mobilisiert zu dieser demonstration es
ist unverständlich dass diese
demonstration in der innenstadt hat
finden können obwohl die maske pflichten
eingehalten worden ist und b ist das
verhalten der polizei nicht ganz
erklärbar angesichts der bedrohung des
starken rechtsextremen potenzials was
ich dort gezeigt hat warum hat die
polizei wird defensiv agiert warum die
versammlung nicht sofort aufgelöst
obwohl von beginn an gegen auflagen
verstoßen wurde rechtfertigungsversuche
jetzt haben wir deeskalierend gewirkt
was unsere sag mal so taktik und
strategie der letzten zeit gewesen ist
und das ist auch wieder nicht richtig da
frage ich mich jedes mal ja was soll die
polizei überhaupt machen wenn wir zu
schlagen heißt es gewalt der polizei wir
haben ein gewalt staat ein polizeistaat
wenn wir nichts war heißt es auch wieder
zu lax gewesen die polizei ja das ist
dann immer die frage die sich dann
nachher gibt und dann schreibtisch dann
zu handeln und dann schreibtisch die
richtige antwort zu geben das ist das
leichteste der welt die bilanz des tages
31 verletzte polizisten 32 übergriffe
auf journalisten eine stadt in
misskredit hat sich ausgesucht worden
ist wann eine gruppierung von einem
sammelsurium von unterschiedlichen
gruppen die aus ganz deutschland
angereist sind meines wissens sind fast
15 20.000 menschen angereist
stuttgart/leipzig wollte die
demonstranten weit draußen haben auf dem
messegelände leichter zu kontrollieren
ein symbolträchtiger ort vor allem aber
mehr platz
das oberverwaltungsgericht in bautzen
machte der stadt einen strich durch die
rechnung bis heute warten sie im rathaus
auf eine begründung
das oberverwaltungsgericht bautzen haben
die richter hier aus ideologischen
gründen geurteilt in der aktuellen
ausgabe der sächsischen verwaltung
splatter findet sich ein dubioser
artikel eines offenbacher rechtsanwalts
der schreibt über die korona pandemie
die krankheit cupid 19 ist im vergleich
mit der gewöhnlichen grippe keine
wesentlich schlimmere die öffentliche
gesundheitsversorgung ist nicht
kollabiert das ist nichts anderes als
eine verharmlosung von kogit 19
mitherausgeber der sächsischen
verwaltungs blätter ist der präsident
des ovg sachsen erich künstler redaktion
der aktuellen ausgabe matthias dehoust
und jürgen mengen beide vorsitzende
richter am ovg am späten abend begründet
das gericht kurz seine entscheidung
demnach wäre die versammlungs fläche um
den augustusplatz groß genug gewesen
dort hätte es eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit gegeben dass sich die
teilnehmer nicht ungeordnet in der
innenstadt verteilt
bautzen mehr als jeder dritte welt hier
afd
die wetter großflächig gegen die korona
maßnahmen geschäfte in der innenstadt
laden menschen ein
auch ohne maske sind sie willkommen
die sache mit gefährlich sehen wir beide
kritisch weil wenn man endstufen als
sehr gefährlich ein ansieht wer erkältet
ist bleibt zu hause und mit abstand von
anderen männern okay man hat ja einen
gesunden menschenverstand nimmt abstand
rücksicht oder geht erst gar nicht raus
weil man sich nicht wohl fühlt ok und
die bilder aus dem frühjahr aus bergamo
ist die frage ob die echt sind
da bin ich sehr am zweifeln wenn die
gewisse gefährlichkeit einige stufe
keine mich ein hilfloses umgehen haben
sozusagen jetzt gibt es nicht das ist
quatsch ignorieren ist der falsche weg
die machen ja die menschen kaputt seit
märz geht das nur noch um zahlen zahlen
zahlen
sie haben das vertrauen sozusagen nicht
dass die dass die politik auf keinen
fall das verlorene vertrauen in die
politik der sächsische ministerpräsident
kämpft dagegen und wirkt dabei oft wie
ein getriebener
michael kretschmer verantwortet die
aktuelle sächsische corona
schutzverordnung mit all ihren
juristischen schlupflöchern die die
ereignisse von leipzig erst möglich
gemacht haben heute der kursschwenk
verkündet vom regierungssprecher weil
der ministerpräsident selbst in
häuslicher quarantäne ist die krone
schutzwohnung wurde heute angepasst
insbesondere der paragraph 9 das
versammlungs geschehen
nach der jetzigen verordnung sind
versammlungen mit einer teilnehmerzahl
mit höchstens 1000 teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmern nur zulässig wenn
verschiedene auflagen erfüllt sind es
ist nicht das erste mal dass die
landesregierung spät reagiert lange
setzte man in sachsen auf das prinzip
der eigenverantwortung bei der
bekämpfung der korona pandemie nur
deshalb waren noch am 25 oktober
aufnahmen wie diese möglich im internet
verbreitet ostsachsen tv-bilder der
dresdner jazztage zu sehen sind dicht
gedrängt menschen ohne abstand und ohne
maske versuchskaninchen in corona zeiten
veranstalter kilian forster selbst
musiker versteht die aufregung gar nicht
es hätte ein hygiene konzept
kontaktlisten gegeben die freiwilligkeit
ist dass man sagt die leute lechzen
danach in ein konzert zu gehen und wir
haben versucht das auch zu ermöglichen
mit vollgas das organisiert und dann
geht man freiwillig rein und man weiß
man kann sich da natürlich infizieren
aber man weiß auch wir haben die kontakt
nachverfolgung können das sofort ans
gesundheitsamt weitergeben ganz sachsen
ist inzwischen corona hochrisiko gebiet
nirgendwo sonst in ostdeutschland sind
die zahlen so hoch wie hier seit vier
wochen explodiert die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen von fast null auf weit
über 1000 das gleiche gilt für die zahl
von kogit 19 patienten in krankenhäusern
täglich neue höchststände in den
krankenhäusern haben sie die lage im
griff doch letztendlich war klar dass
irgendwann eine welle kommen würde
nochmal das hat sich also angedeutet und
deswegen konnten wir die notwendigen
vorkehrungsmaßnahmen treffen und sind
jetzt nicht überrollt wurden
das erzgebirge trifft es doppelt hart
bundesweit spitze bei den täglichen
neuinfektionen nun bricht das gesamte
weihnachtsgeschäft weg erzgebirgische
handwerkskunst ist der renner auf
deutschlands weihnachtsmärkten
doch die sind allesamt abgesagt 150
firmen bleiben auf ihrem
weihnachtsschmuck sitzen die stimmung
mies natürlich auch immer noch
optimistisch gerade fall auch in sachsen
die zahlen eher niedrig waren
wir haben natürlich auch schon
produziert unsere produkte werden alle
in handarbeit hergestellt es dauert
einfach sehr lange bis wir auch
entsprechende stückzahlen für diese ein
drittel vom jahresumsatz herstellen
können und wären sie im erzgebirge wegen
corona um ihre wirtschaftliche existenz
bangen demonstrierten sie in leipzig als
ob es das virus gar nicht gebe ein super
special event der extraklasse
verantwortung dafür wir bislang niemand
übernehmen und die nächsten querdenken
demos sind bereits geplant
[Musik]